(snap with echo)
- How do I feel?
I feel pretty solid.
I feel like there's some nuances
that are indicating implicit,
other than the fact that
Instagram's organic reach is finished.
So just as we figured it out, it's over.
It's over!
Yeah!
- Yeah!
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk!
- [Gary] I just wanna be happy.
(midtempo R&B influenced music)
Do you know how many people have
emailed me in the last,
and when I say emailed, DM'ed
in the last hundred days
that have said to me,
I cannot believe how many followers
I have on TikTok
after seven years of going hard
on YouTube and Instagram
within 31 days,
I have a bigger audience,
more impactful on my happiness
or my business results on TikTok.
Thank you!
So I'm just gonna fuckin'
put the blueprint out for free.
I'm putting out the whole fucking game.
The map, the fucking key,
the blueprint, what do
you want to call it?
The crystal ball?
(laughs)
Call it whatever the
fuck you wanna call it.
I'm putting out for 0.00 cents,
and then I'm gonna let the cards play out.
I can't worry about if I'm gonna get you
to get to do it.
I'm just gonna pressure you
in perpetuity to put in your fuckin' face
that it can be done,
here's the fuckin' maps.
Here's the fuckin' blueprint.
And I'm just gonna wait for
person on person on person.
Every day.
'Can't believe I just went
on Facebook yesterday.
'Just went on Facebook Marketplace,
'made 900 bucks, I can't believe it!
'Been listening to Gary say this
'for 18 months, I finally did it, wow!'
TikTok, LinkedIn.
I'm gonna put out free game
for the rest of my fuckin' life,
and when it's all over,
a lot of fuckin' people
are gonna do somethin' about it.
Which is why everyone's
comin' to my funeral.
(laughs)
And I'll be really, really mad
if you don't come.
- [Man] Right.
(laughs)
- Dustin, I'll be real
mad at you, specifically.
(reflective hip hop beat)
(dramatic music)
What?
(laughs)
(static)
So many people are scared to do.
And one of the things I
see people scared to do
is jump on a new platform
when it's emerging.
And they're worried about wasting time,
will it still be around, will it be big?
That's always a bad idea
because there's so many learnings
and if it's potentially huge,
one out of eight times,
that will pay for all your
other seven times wasted.
However, if you right now
target 50 to 80 year olds,
it doesn't mean that you
have to be on TikTok.
I'm very comfortable
that if you're targeting
50 to 80 year olds for mortgages
that TikTok makes a lot
less sense than LinkedIn.
That's when you maybe spend
.1 percent of your strategy and time
looking at it.
I do think that you should get an account.
I do think that you
maybe should look at it.
Why?
Because LinkedIn may create a feature,
a meme or a story feature
that maybe something you've seen in TikTok
makes you create better on LinkedIn.
If you're targeting 14 to 18 year olds,
trying to sell them hoodies,
you should be spending 50 to 70 percent
of your time on TikTok.
So yes, these are not blanket statements,
and if you have an older demo,
I have no problem with you
not "doing it", quote-unquote.
To me, that is one percent of your time,
downloading the app,
and looking for human
behavior tactics and nuances
that may help you in the places
you do market.
You may hear a term on TikTok
that changes the term you use
in the title of your email
that makes that email
convert four percent better.
You understand?
That was thoughtful.
Good advice
is not required to stay in any room.
You can get good advice on LinkedIn,
you can get good advice on TikTok,
you can get good advice in the corner
at a cafe.
Good content has no
boundaries of distribution.
I mean the TikTok thing
is playing out right in
everyone's fuckin' face.
The fuckin' clip we just put on Instagram.
What up, bro?
How are you?
- Good.
- What's your name?
- Harrison.
- Harrison, nice to meet you, brother.
- [DRock] Where did you find Gary?
- What?
- [DRock] Where'd you find him?
- On TikTok.
- What the gentleman
just said on the podcast,
and everyone's reacting,
'cause for a lot of people
it's their first rodeo and I'm like,
I've fuckin' seen this movie before.
Of course every 11 year old's
gonna be about the content.
There are universal truths.
And we post-produce!
We think about the music.
We think about the meme overlay.
We think!
That's right.
Especially the context.
Understanding the context
of the distribution.
That is the slang, that is the culture.
You have to know what you want to say,
you have to know the culture, right?
You have to know what is cool.
You have to know that a sneak
and Slatt means something to
an 18 year old in Atlanta.
And then you have to know
how to actually make it
for Instagram, it's a three prong attack.
Listen.
Follow 700 accounts.
Download the app.
Follow all the things that explore
or pops up in your feed.
Search cars, wine, sneakers, lawyers,
search your thing.
Follow 53 accounts
that show up in those hashtags
of your thing.
Open the app every day for 10 minutes
consume, consume, consume, consume,
then talk.
- I want to make sure
and give this to you as well, so
my stepdaughter is 12.
And I listen to your podcast
when my wife and I are in the car
and they're watching movies in the back.
And I didn't realize
she had stumbled across
you on TikTok, and had
(laughs)
yeah, right?
And, she put two and two together
that the podcast I was
listening to was Gary.
She found out I was coming,
on her own, right before I left, she said,
please give this to Gary.
- What's her name?
- Her name is Reese.
- Reese.
- I don't know where my phone's at.
- I have it.
(laughs)
Reese.
How are you?
It's Gary Vee.
This is incredible.
If you want to start a business with me
selling your drawings, I'm in.
(click)
If you do not produce content for
YouTube, LinkedIn and Facebook every day,
as a real estate, and Instagram,
as a real estate or mortgage professional,
you're losing.
Figure it out.
That's a big statement.
I know that sounds scary,
you haven't posted anything
and now I'm asking you
four fuckin' platforms a day?
Go Google.
Go learn, how do I post on YouTube?
(clicks pen)
I'm givin' you the statement there.
I don't need to give
you tactics, my friends,
it's called Google.
You don't know how to make a video?
Google.
I don't even know what Final Cut Pro is,
I could figure everything they all do,
I can do in a day.
It's called Google.
Actually, for me, it's YouTube,
I can't read for shit.
I'd have to watch it.
But I'd know.
(snaps)
Keep yourself,
God, I hate fuckin'
I hate people that talk
something they don't live.
Plenty of leaders talking about
keep learning everyday!
Yet refuse to fuckin' learn.
Before I think we started the podcast,
'cause I don't think
was here,
we talked about your daughter
knowing who I am.
I'm living my truth.
I tell you to keep doing it,
I keep doing it.
I've got a million followers on TikTok.
That's not fuckin'
bragging about my following on TikTok.
That's me living my fuckin' truth.
TikTok didn't even cross my mind
on January first.
Actually it did.
But, it wasn't ready.
(midtempo spacy beat)
Good afternoon.
Yep, afternoon.
I'm just sending you a text
to fuckin' make!
This is about making!
Less thinking!
- [DRock] Ideas and making.
- Ideas and making.
Just fuckin' make!
- Ah, ah, ahh!
You didn't say the magic word!
- I gotta do a couple other things.
(light chuckle)
I'm feeling like everyone's
doing well except you.
And Lou.
- [Man] That makes a ton of sense.
(laughs)
I agree.
- And possibly Caleb as well.
But everybody else who's not in this car
is fucking crushing it.
(laughs)
Oh, and Avi's struggling.
- [DRock] Avi.
- And I'm the fuckin' worst.
How do I feel?
I feel pretty solid.
I feel like there's some nuances
that are indicating implicit,
other than the fact that
Instagram's organic reach is finished.
So just as we figured it out, it's over.
It's over!
Yeah, organic reach on Instagram
has started the process of it being over.
So now everyone's about to be.
Everyone's influencer
career is about to end.
What's up, Brandon?
(inaudible)
I'm now talking to you,
how's everything at Wine Text?
(laughs)
(rock pop instrumental)
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk!
(audience applauds)
- TikTok.
(audience laughs)
The same phenomenon's happening on TikTok.
I have empathy why a
lot of people will say,
well, that is not where my audience is.
But that would be because
people were playing checkers,
and they're not playing chess,
and they don't realize that
the number one influencer
on buying things in America is the Mom,
and the person that
influences the Mom the most
is the daughter.
You could have an entire strategy
on targeting 14 year old girls
on TikTok to make a business transaction
happen with the Mom.
You could!
A, you have to have the strategy
and the knowledge to know
what I just said is true.
Two, you then have to put out content
that inspires a 14 year old
to tell their Mom about it
which is no easy task!
(audience laughs)
That's a creative struggle,
you have to be very clever,
but it's not impossible.
But the amount of organic reach
on that platform and for whatever reason,
if your side hustle or your actual job
creates a world where you're
trying to market to 12 to 18 year olds,
you should be spending 50 to 70 percent
of your time on TikTok.
The growth is uncomfortable.
And it is the only platform right now
in the world that has the potential
to dethrone Instagram as
the top app in culture.
It may not age up the way that
Vine and Socialcam and others did not.
But it might.
Because I will remind all of you
that Instagram started off as a app
to help people take better
photos and had filters.
Or Facebook was a
college-only social network.
These things age up.
So, this is what I spend all my time on.
Underpriced attention.
(reflective hip hop beat)
- This is my first Facebook Live video.
- Let's go, Facebook Live!
(laughs)
What's good?
Oh it's five viewers
too, my favorite number!
- Five!
- What's good, Paul!
Bubba, Shin!
What's good, Shin?
Jess, what's up?
- Girlfriend, uncle.
- Girlfriend, uncle, who's Paul?
- That's my uncle.
- Oh, who's Bubba?
- He's the O.G.
- Big O.G.!
- What about Shin?
- Oh, that's my girl.
- That's awesome.
- She's the boss.
- So who's Jessica?
- I don't even know Jessica.
(laughs)
(reflective hip hop beat)
- There's some real good clips there.
You guys, if you didn't miss 'em.
I think the funniest one
is the one where I grab it, go live,
say that it's five people,
we go through all the people,
and I thought Jess was his girlfriend,
he goes, nah that's my girlfriend,
and I go, well who's Jess?
The first person, he didn't catch it.
And he goes, I don't know, hey, Jess!
(group laughs)
And I wanna title it, Wait For It
'cause you'll have no clue
how it, that will kill!
It's kind of like that, the
big meme of all time, right?
Where it's like, the guy
walking with the girl
looking back at the other girl.
I think it has crazy potential.
Call Little Lou and tell him
am I going to real estate conferences
and any time I am, to tell you.
You know what I mean?
And he will, he's good like that.
Little Lou's pretty organized.
- [Lou] Really?
- You don't think you're
organized, Little Lou?
- [Lou] I don't think I am.
- Really?
You're fired.
(laughs)
I mean, you gotta be, I mean, jeez!
What do you mean?
That's the only, that's the
prerequisite for the job!
- You're telling me I'm organized, that's
- I mean, you're finished, Lou!
(laughs)
- [Lou] If you're
telling me I'm organized,
awesome, I just never feel
- Well, I'm so not organized
that everyone, anybody who's like
puts something into a little calendar
(laughs)
input is like, 'you were very organized!'
- [Lou] Cool!
- No, nobody thinks I'm organized.
(reflective hip hop beat)
Great day in the city.
Nice little vlog vlog.
Bunch of big quotes.
Hopefully Caleb and DRock didn't miss it.
Lou made a cameo,
now not on Trash Talk, which is rare.
(laughs)
You loved him on Trash Talk, now he's
in admin life.
If you loved him on Trash Talk,
really sharp day, going to
have an operations meeting now.
For three hours.
Which is a lot of stuff
you guys don't see.
Three, and
just feeling good.
Feeling focused, feeling excited,
hopefully Sam Darnold's spleen
will get cleared on Friday.
And, some good news today?
Practicing?
- Practicing, non-contact.
But if you're practicing,
I thought they would've let him practice
know what I mean?
- I'm not sure.
See ya, hope you enjoy.
Subscribe, leave a comment.
212-931-5731.
Text me.
- [Man] The fact that
you've memorized that number
- [Man] Thanks, dude.
(laughs)
- The text I just sent, "just make",
somebody took it, put it on Twitter
and said, "find a significant other
"who supports you the way Gary V does."
(laughs)
Well done.